hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip i'm cameron and today we're
talking about
chromatic aberration specifically two
ways to easily create chromatic
aberration
without third-party plug-ins there's a
lot of third-party plug-ins out there
to create chromatic aberration and they
can give you some amazing results
but if you don't have a third party
plugin this is a way you can manually
create
chromatic aberration so two ways the
first way we're going to talk about you
may have seen this before is
got my footage here i'm going to go to
effect channel
shift channels we're going to
keep red on green is
full off blue
is full off so now we've got just our
red channel here so think of rgb this is
red for r
we're going to duplicate this footage
come back up here to red
full off green is on
so now we've got our green channel we're
going to set this to a transfer mode of
screen
so now it's starting to look like our
original image
we're going to duplicate one more time
and bring the blue channel in
so we're going to go up here to green
full off
blue is on and now we're back to our
original image here
okay so i'm gonna take a screenshot of
this
so we can remember how this originally
looked
and we'll go ahead and screenshot right
there and all we have to do now is just
select our bottom layer and just nudge
our position so we can maybe say 9
61. let's move it a little bit over you
know one pixel let's try two pixels
let's go a little bit farther let's go
964 and you can really start to see
what's happening right here
as i zoom in here you can see some
chromatic aberration really happening up
here
if i go back and show our original image
that's the original
this is the new chromatic aberration so
again we're four pixels off here which
is quite a bit chromatic aberration is
typically
very very subtle and i'm just using my
arrow key and i'm nudging it back
you know maybe something in there that's
the original
that's the new chromatic aberration
sometimes i'll also take the top layer
maybe nudge it up a couple pixels you
know up
maybe left a little bit just to give it
a little bit
different look and there you go it's
very very subtle
but there is our chromatic aberration in
technique number one now let's move on
to technique number two again we've got
the same
footage here and we're going to go to
effect
and we're going to go down here to
perspective and we're going to select
3d glasses yes it sounds kind of strange
but just just trust me on this one so
what we're going to do here is we're
going to
set our left view to our original
footage
there we go looking a little strange
we're going to set our 3d view to
balance
color red blue there we go
and now the magic happens with scene
convergence and vertical alignment
i found for this one a value of 2
actually let's do a value of negative 2
and a positive value of vertical
alignment two and there you go there is
our very simple chromatic aberration
again with using the 3d glasses feature
so this is
without and this is width so again this
is a little bit
too much so maybe i'll go negative one
and a positive one so that's with
and without again maybe it might be
still you know too much with the
vertical so maybe i'd
crank this down to say 0.5 maybe make
this
a negative 0.5 and with
and without so very subtle here but this
is a really simple way
to add chromatic aberration to
your footage or your typography inside
of after effects